Hello world. It's a Raj and
Yolo. You only look once.
That is the demo.
For today's video we're going to build
an object detection algorithm called
Yolo.
You only look once for real time video
so you can feed this thing on Avi Mov any
kind of MP four file and it's going to
be able to in real time like this demo
that you're seeing behind me that I'm
running off of my laptop in real time,
be able to detect what objects are where.
Now this is one of the most popular and
one of the most new techniques out there
for object detection.
So in this video I'm going to go over
a little bit of the history of object
detection techniques just over the past
decade or so so we can really see why
Yolo is so impressive.
Then I'm going to go over the architecture
of Yolo and then at the end we're
going to go through the code and we're
going to use it on both a pre trained
model and we're going to learn how to
build our own Yolo model as well. Okay.
So I hope you're excited
for this cause I am. Right.
So let's get right on into it.
So let's start off with some object
detection history starting from 2001 so in
2001 the first really good facial
detection algorithm came out and it was
created by two guys,
Paul Viola and Michael Jones.
And so it was aptly named
the Viola Jones Algorithm.
And this was the first time that facial
detection really worked for a Webcam.
And so, I mean object detection has
been around since the sixties this is,
this is nothing new,
right?
But this was the first time that it
really worked better than anything else.
And they're out rhythm did what all the
other algorithms in general did before
them. They hand coded in features
and fed them into a classifier,
namely a support vector machine. So it
was trained on a Dataset of bases. Right?
And they would,
they would hand code the location
of eyes of the mouth of the nose,
and then their relations to each
other. Right. So as great as it was,
as at detecting faces,
it was really bad at detecting faces
in any other kind of configuration than
what the hand coded features
said. Right? So wanted,
once they collected these
features by hand, by manually
for each of these images,
these features were vectors,
right?
And they would feed all these vectors
together for a single image into a support
vector machine. A classifier, right?
I support vector machine can
act as a linear classifier,
a binary classifier. Yes,
no, and that was it. Real face or
not a real face. And this worked.
This worked really well at the time.
And here you can see some
pseudocode of how it worked,
but basically for each of the images they
would down sample the image to create
an image, which is, which in this
case is actually a feature, right?
And then they would iteratively
add all those features up together.
They would concatenate them
and then accumulate a set,
a series of filter outputs and feed all
of those outputs to a support vector
machine. If you want to know how
support vector machines work,
check out my math of
intelligence playlist. Okay.
So then in 2005 a much more
efficient technique came out,
still using features,
hand coded features,
but it was called hog or histograms of
oriented gradients and it was invented by
it, a veep Delo and build tricks. So
the basic idea of this algorithm was,
was for for every image. So for faces,
right? Namely they applied it to faces,
but they also applied it to
pedestrian detection on roads,
which is really useful,
right? For self driving cars,
for traffic lights for things
like that. But the idea was, okay,
you've got an image of a face,
right? You've got an image of a face.
And the goal is how dark is the current
pixel compared to all the surrounding
pixels.
So for every single pixel in an image,
they would detect how dark it was
compared to the surrounding pixels.
And then they drew an Arrow showing in
which direction the image got darker.
Okay.
And so they repeated that process
for every single pixel in the image.
So every pixel was then
replaced by an arrow.
And this Arrow was called a gradient,
not a gradient in the sense
of backpropagation for
neural networks, a gradient,
just, they're just using
that word for this, right?
So the gradient show the flow from
light to dark across the entire image.
So this is what picture
would eventually look like.
It would go from a series of pixels,
a matrix of pixels into a
matrix of gradients or arrows,
which point which direction
things are getting darker.
And so then once they had that, they
broke up the image into small squares,
16 by 16 pixels each.
And then in each square they counted up
how many gradients point in each major
direction.
And they were placed that square in the
image with the Arrow directions that
were the strongest. So in that, in that
region, what direction was most prevalent?
Right?
And they would replace the square and
the image with arrows in that direction.
And the end result of this is that the
original image was converted into a
simple representation
that looked like this.
That was basically it captured the
basics. The essence of a face, right?
And so and so they can use this
image to then given a new face,
they can use some sort of
similarity metric like you know,
you know the Euclidean distance or any
of the various distance metrics that we
could use to detect how similar it
was to whatever image it was given.
And based on some threshold value, they
could say, yes, this is a face or no,
this is not a face.
So recall that this kind
of basic feature map right,
that they've generated looks very similar
to what convolutional nets learned
themselves.
But in this case they had to hand
code what this feature map looks like.
So then in 2012 the era of
deep learning began, right?
This is when every so often
in in computer science,
an idea comes along that just makes you
not only rethink your existing ideas but
completely discard your existing ideas.
And that's what deep learning was, right?
So in 2012 for the image net competition,
this is a yearly competition to train
for, for researchers to try to, you know,
try out their algorithms and see who can
outperform the other Kurczewski and his
team with Hinton use a convolutional
network that outperformed everybody else
for image net.
Right?
So for this was in 2012 but the thing
is that convoluted is convolutional nets
had been around since the 90s why did
they work this time? If you can answer,
you get bonus points. There are
two reasons. It's because of a,
lots of gps and lots of data that's,
that's a difference.
They gave it lots of computing
power and lots of data.
Now the thing about humans, we're really
good at classifying images, right?
We're really good at this,
but we do more than just classify images.
So notice that whenever there's
a classification task, yes or no,
is it there or not? That's it,
right? That's classification.
Whenever there is a classification task,
the images that we feed
these models just have the,
the the class in question as a center
of the image. Like, if it's a dog,
you'll just see a dog, maybe a white
background, but it's just a dog.
But the thing is when we look around
at the world, right, it's not just,
we're not just classifying things,
we are detecting things.
That means that we are not just
identifying what an object is,
but we are classifying.
But we're detecting the
boundaries around that.
Object to the differences of that object
with the other objects in the images
and the relations between all the objects.
So the question is can convolutional
nets as great as they are,
a classification also help at detection.
That is not just detecting whether
or not an image is in a picture,
right as a single image, but, but,
but detecting if that image exists,
what its relation is to other images.
Can we build a bounding box around that
image? Is the image partially occluded?
But we can still see it? Yes.
The answer is yes. Right.
And this was proven by a team that
was very recently. This was proven.
But one very basic thing we
can do is we can say, okay,
let's take an existing
convolutional net and repurpose it,
repurpose it as an object, a texture
detector. How are we going to do that?
Now let me tell you how
we're going to do that.
We can take any existing classifier,
VGG net inception.
These are huge convolutional nets
that were trained on huge data sets,
right by Google,
et cetera.
And what we can do is we can take our
image in question. Let's say it's,
let's say it's this image here and we
want to detect her car and Vg Nett and
obviously the tech a car because it was
trained on car images amongst many other
classes.
What we can do is we can slide the
classifier over every single, um,
over a bunch of squares of
that image, right? So we can,
we can classify every single region as
we define maybe a 12 by 12 pixel region
for every single one. And so as
we're sliding it across the image,
we're just continuously classifying
every single box, right? Of this image.
We're going to get a bunch
of different classifications.
We were going to get a bunch of different
classifications and then we can only
keep the ones at the classifier
is the most certain about,
and we can use that to then draw
a bounding box around the image.
But this is a very brute force approach,
right? We don't, we're not just going to,
this is a very computationally expensive
approach. We don't want to just do that,
that that's, that's done
this. That's not a good way.
There's gotta be a more efficient
way of doing things. Right?
So a better approach was invented
just two years ago called CNN.
Okay.
So the idea behind our CNN was,
before they feed it,
they fed it to a convolutional network.
They would use a process called selective
search to create a set of bounding
boxes. Or in the paper they called
them region proposals in an image.
So at a high level,
the selective search process process
looks at an image through a series of
windows of different sizes, right?
These are just randomly size,
randomly placed windows.
And for each size it tries to group
together adjacent pixels by texture,
color, or intensity to identify
objects. So given some input and image,
the first step is to generate a set of
region proposals for bounding boxes for
however many we want by some threshold,
right? And then once we have that,
we run those images in the bounding
boxes through a pretrained,
Alex snap or whatever kind of CNN.
We want to compute the
features for that bounding box.
And then finally a support vector machine
to classify to see what the object in
the image in the box, what the
object, the image in the box is of.
Then we run the box through a linear
regression model to output tighter
coordinates for the box once
the object has been classified.
And this proved to be an effective
approach for object detection.
The most effective by
repurposing a convolutional
network for object detection,
by using this selective search algorithm
to create bounding boxes beforehand and
then feeding all of those boxes to a CNN
to compute a list of features and then,
and then computing class values from them.
So for RCA are for our CNN,
there had been lots of improvements
like lots of fast. Our CNN baster,
our CNN mask,
our CNN and I've got papers and links
to them all here in the description.
Uh, actually mask our CNN
just came out this year.
But yellow I think is the best approach
and not just because of the name.
Yolo is the best approach, um,
because it outperformed all of them.
It outperformed our CNN and all
of its variance that I know of.
Maybe some guy just yesterday invented
some new version of our CNN, I don't know.
But as far as I know,
Yolo is uh,
the state of the art in
object detection and Yolo,
it takes a completely different approach,
which is very exciting. All right,
so check this out.
So Yolo,
Yolo does is it's not a
traditional classifier that's
repurposed to be an object
detector like our CNN.
What it does is it actually just looks
at the image once hence its name.
You only look once,
but in a clever way.
Let's say we've got this image right and
we want to is tact all the classes that
are in the image. We've got
a dog, we've got a bike,
we've got a car in the background.
How are we going to do this?
So what Yolo says is let's
divide up the image into a grid,
a 13 by 13 cells.
And so each of these cells is responsible
for predicting five bounding boxes.
So some part of a bounding box is going
to intersect into that little square
that the, that that is that
little square, right? So it's,
it's responsible for
detecting up to five of them.
Like it could be part of this one part
of this one part of this one or this one,
right,
but five and so what a bounding box does,
cause it describes the rectangle
that encloses some object.
Yolo is also going to output a confidence
score that tells us how certain it is
that the predicted downing box
actually encloses some object.
So it's not just PR trying to predict
whether or not a set of bounding boxes
exist.
It's also each of these
squares is predicting what
the class is for each of the
bounding boxes that it's
predicted the existence of.
And so the score doesn't say anything
about what kind of object is in the box.
Just if the shape of the box is any good.
So the predicting bounding boxes may
look something like the following,
the higher the confidence score,
the fatter the box that is drawn.
So notice for our Doggie,
for our bike,
we've got some really thick
bounding boxes, meaning that it,
it can tell that there is
something significant there.
So each of the bounding boxes,
the s for each bounding box to
sell also predicts a class, right?
It's predicting two things,
whether or not a bounding box exists.
And then the class of that bounding box,
and this works just like a classifier,
it gives a probability distribution over
all the possible trick classes that the
network has been trained on.
It's a convolutional network.
So Yolo was trained on
the Pascal voc data set,
which has 20 different classes like
bicycles and boats and cars and dogs,
and the confidence score
for the bounding box.
And the class prediction are combined
into one final score that tells the
probability that this bounding box
contains a specific type of object.
For example,
the big fat yellow box here on the left
is 85% sure that it contains the object
dog. So based on some kind of
threshold value, like 80% plus,
we can just leave that bounding
box there that we decide.
So since there are 13 by 13 grid cells
and each cell is predicting five bounding
boxes, we end up with 845
downing box boxes in total.
That's a lot of bounding boxes,
but it turns out that most of these boxes
are going to have very low confidence
scores.
So we only keep the boxes whose
final score is 30% or more.
Like I said, whatever threshold
value we want. And once we do that,
the end result is going to be this.
We're going to have only
three bounding boxes left,
and these three bounding boxes had scores
that were higher than our threshold
value, 30% and as you can see, that's
exactly what we wanted to detect.
But the, this, the key here,
the secret of why Yolo is so good is
because it's not just that from the 845
total bounding boxes,
we only kept three of them,
but it's that even though there
were 845 separate predictions,
they were all made at the
same time, right? Yolo,
you only look once the
convolutional network is only
looking once we are feeding
all of these boxes to the neural
network all at once, right?
So it is a convolutional network,
right? And the architecture is very,
very simple. This is what it looks like,
right? You've got input, convolution,
pooling, convolution,
pooling, convolution, pooling,
right over and over and over again.
And there are actually several versions
of Yolo out there, or there's Yolo.
And then there's Yolo [inaudible] also
called yellow, 9,000 better, faster,
stronger. I know these names are
just going crazy. I love it though.
[inaudible] memes and signs together
when total win, right? So, uh,
this is what it looks like.
Uh, and so by the way,
we're going to be looking at
yellow to just skip Yolo one.
Cause Yolo too is obviously
better. Uh, so, uh, we,
what we're to do is once we feed our
bounding boxes into our convolutional
network, we're going to end up with 125
channels for every single Brits Self.
And these 125 numbers contain the data
for the bounding boxes and the class
predictions.
And the reason it's 125 is because each
grid cell predicts five bounding boxes
and a bounding boxes described by 25 data
elements. And these are the elements,
the x fly, that's the
locations, the coordinates,
the width and height for the
bounding box was rectangle,
the confidence score and the probability
distribution over the classes using it.
It's very simple. You give
it an input image, right?
It goes through the convolutional network
in a single pass and it comes out the
other end as a 13 by 13 by 125,
uh,
sized tensor describing the
bounding boxes for the grid cells.
And all you need to do then is compute
the final scores for the bounding boxes
and throw away the ones that
are scoring less than 30%.
And so yola two is better
because it's faster,
it understands more generalized object
representations and you can find a paper
for it here. Okay. So what I want
to do now is go through some code.
So let's go through some code.
This is,
this is probably the best implementation
of a Yolo too that I found on get hub
so far. So, uh, originally the,
the authors of Yolo wrote it in this,
uh,
wrote it in dark nets.
So dark net is a,
is an open source neural network library.
And See,
I know why didn't they just
use tensorflow, but they
wrote it in dark net and um,
yeah, it's written foresee and
Kuta. It's fast. It's great if you,
if you want to work with see work with,
see,
but basically the best implementation
I've found is called dark flow.
So what this guy did is he translated
dark net to a tensorflow virgin and we can
use dark flow to do several things.
And I'm going,
I'm going to do it with you right now.
Okay, let's get started to hear right.
So we can choose one of the following
three ways to get started with dark flow.
I've downloaded it here so you can
just clone it, calling it locally,
and then you can set it up.
So the first step is to run setup.py.
No module named Scythe on. Okay,
so then I'll install Saigon.
Okay,
so that's the first step we're going to,
we're going to set up cy
thon and once it's done that,
then we can install all
of our dependencies.
And the reason we're using Psiphon is
because right darknet is written in c and
we need some kind of rapper to introduce
these c libraries to our python
environment.
So now I can go ahead and install
Paul our dependencies.
That'll take some time. Okay, that
was it. That was our dependencies.
And so now let's go ahead
and download some weights.
Okay,
so downloaded this,
this pretrained weights
and I'm going to open them.
Tonya will awaits
right here.
Okay,
now I want to load these weights up.
Okay.
So let's look at this code
for a bit. Um, all right,
so for the code we can see
that it is quite a big project,
but if we look under net,
we're going to see some of the versions
of the different yellow implementations.
So we can just go to, uh,
let's see where we can go to.
We can go to Yolo v two.
Okay.
So if we go to build.py, we can see the
tensorflow implementation of dark net.
So remember, because this
was written in c, uh,
we are not using tensorflow native
functions to build this convolutional
network. So when we go into
the in function, we'll see
that the s there are some,
you know, boiler plate flags for
how to train this network. Uh,
and there are different ways
of building this network.
We can build it from a
pretrained PB file and you know,
that's how we save files and tensorflow
as dot PB. That's one of the ways.
And when we build the Ford Pass,
like this is kind of where the
convolutional network is built.
We have some placeholder that the input
data can go through that is namely the
image or the video,
whatever it is.
And then iteratively they're
taking all the ex, the,
the author took the existing dark net
layers and they're adding them to tensor
flow just like right here. Okay. So,
and then we have a bunch of flags and
then we have a way to save the file once
we've trained it.
So,
but the basic idea is that we can use
a pretrained version of this model that
was trained in Si by
downloading weights and then uh,
using the train.py file to train
it on our video or on our images.
And then lastly,
we can then we can then predict what the
bounding boxes are going to be by using
predictive, the predict our
pi a class. Right. Okay.
So there are several things we can do.
We can train our model using our
own data set. We can use a PR,
we can use pretrained weights, we can
train it on images, we can train on video.
But for this demo,
why don't we just use a pre trend
model that they already have, right?
The author has weights that
we can download and then
we can train it on one of
our own videos, right? So
if I just paste this in,
we can train it on one of our own videos
and then we can see the results for
ourselves, right? Just like that.
And so now this is detecting
all the objects in the video,
in the video using yellow.
It's awesome. And uh, yeah,
if you want to do this yourself, it's
pretty simple. I've got the code,
the description,
the slides that I was talking about,
everything is in the video description
and the get hub link. So check them out.
And I hope that you found this useful.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos.
And for now I've got to think of some
Yolo maims. So thanks for watching.